Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since the
back half of this season on The Flash is going
to be littered with Rogues, I wanted to do
a bonus video explaining the ones they’re
doing.
Or at least the ones they’ve announced so
far.
And a few they might still add.
They just cast Peyton List as Lisa Snart aka
Golden Glider.
She’s Captain Cold’s sister.
I’m sure Robbie Amell was pumped to hear
that.
Now they can add The Tomorrow People to the
list of shows they’re snagging people from.
Prison Break, Spartacus and now Tomorrow People.
She won’t appear till Episode 16, but Episode
17, the one right after that, will feature
Mark Hamill reprising his Trickster character
from the original Flash series.
This video will mostly be about Heatwave because
he’s in the promo for the next episode and
all the new Rogues they’ve already announced.
So who are the Rogues?
If you haven’t read the comics, they’re
a revolving cast of misfits with B-Level abilities
that act as a crime gang in both Central City
and Keystone City.
The size of their gang changes from comic
to comic, but there are always a couple of
core members that stay the same.
The oldest ones from the classic comics are
Captain Cold, Heatwave, Weather Wizard, Trickster,
Mirror Master, Pied Piper, Golden Glider,
Abra Kadabra and The Top.
Most of those people are already on the show.
In the early 2000s they introduced Double
Down, Tar Pit, Plunder, Girder and Murmur
The New 52 version of the rogues if very close
to the classic version.
But there have also been alternate groups,
like the Renegades, which are a future version
of their group from the 25th Century, but
the twist is that their like a police task
force.
And during Final Crisis, Inertia creates this
splinter group called the New Rogues as a
way to piss the original Rogues off and blackmail
them into working for him.
Since the TV Show is still in season 1 they’re
mostly sticking with the classic versions
of the characters.
Anytime you’re looking for Rogue easter
eggs in their episodes mostly be looking for
stuff from the original versions of the characters
all the way through Geoff Johns Run pre-Flashpoint.
So far they’ve introduced Weather Wizard
in episode 1, Captain Cold and Heatwave in
Episode 4, the post credits scene from that
is where Captain Cold actually forms the Rogues
officially when he says “I’m forming a
new team”.
Girder debuted in Episode 6, as far as we
know he died in Episode 7 helping them fight
Blackout.
He only appears in the comics during Flashpoint
so I don’t consider Blackout a Rogue.
Captain Boomerang is only mentioned in the
Flash vs Arrow Crossover episode.
And then the Reverse Flash finally appeared
in Episode 9.
He’s technically not a rogue, but a lot
of his stories in the comics get tied up with
the Rogues.
He either uses them or they cross paths because
they’re both trying to take out one of the
Flashes, Barry Allen, Wally West or Bart Allen.
So don’t be surprised if by the end of Season
1 or in the finale.
They Rogues and The Reverse Flash appear on
screen together.
As far as we know Captain Cold’s gun is
the most effective weapon against him.
And now based on their fight in episode 9,
we know Firestorm’s powers work really well
against him.
I guess I should also say that on very rare
occasions, Captain Cold has worked with The
Flash, when it’s suited him.
He might be a criminal, but he does live by
a code.
I already did a video for Captain Cold so
I’ll add a link in the description if you
want to watch it after this but at the time
they had not cast his sister.
Lisa Snart or Golden Glider.
That’s Peyton List.
He turned to a life of crime to support his
sister, they came from an abusive household,
so when they both took off, he took it on
himself to support her, keep her safe.
That’s why he became a bank robber.
After he got the cold gun things got a little
crazy, but you get the idea.
He’s not out to get the flash, all he cares
about is his sister.
Robbing people and mercenary work are the
only options he sees.
So meeting Peyton List on the show is going
to be a lot of fun.
In the comics, she became a Rogue in her own
right, and in the new 52 she even got her
own special powers.
But since the show is going with the classic
versions, if she does end up committing any
crimes.
She’ll probably look a little more like
a Cat Burglar.
The dynamic between her and Wenworth Miller
is going to be so much fun.
She’s like the voice of reason out of that
whole bunch.
Heatwave, who’s being played by fellow Prison
Break Alum Dominic Purcell is the flipside
of that.
He’s not related to Captain Cold, but they’ve
been friends for most of their adult lives.
Heatwave, as the name implies is a powder
keg of ego waiting to explode.
He’s got an ichy trigger finger and he’s
not very bright and he causes a lot of collateral
damage for the rogues.
He and Captain Cold butt heads in the comics
a lot.
Song of Ice and Fire.
It’s right out of Game of Thrones.
The show kind of teased that in episode 4
in that post credits scene where Wentworth
Miller is like “i know that last job didn’t
go so well…”
As far as we know, they’ll be the only two
Rogues in episode 10.
But it’s called Revenge of the Rogues, which
is a reference to the comic book storyline
“Rogues Revenge”.
I think it’s a reference in name only, because
Rogues Revenge was from Final Crisis and it
involved Bart Allen and Inertia and a lot
of characters we don’t have on the show
yet.
So this is mostly going to be the Rogues first
mission as a team.
With Caitlin being used as blackmail.
They’re probably after Star LABS tech or
they want The Flash to steal something for
them.
It’s going to be a lot of fun.
Expect Dominic Purcell to go completely crazy.
The next new Rogue we’ll meet is Pied Piper.
He’s actually in two episodes 11 and 12.
Just like in the comics, he’s also Captain
Singh’s boyfriend.
Although I don’t think Captain Singh knows
anything about him becoming a criminal.
Episode 11 will probably just tease the character
and then episode 12 will be full blown pied
piper.
One of the more interesting things about him
is that he was born deaf.
The show is changing that, on the show he’ll
be another former Star Labs genius who had
a falling out with Harrison Wells.
So think Blackout Revenge Episode 7 stuff.
In this version the particle accelerator explosion
will be the reason he goes deaf.
As the name implies, his abilities give him
the power of hypnotism.
One really cool thing about him from the comics
was that he possessed The Anti-Life Equation.
Which was something Darkseid used to try and
control the minds of every living being.
It was this mathematical equation that was
supposed to prove the futility of life.
Grant Morrison is the most recent person to
use the idea in a story.
But they might turn it into an easter egg
on the show.
Most of Grant Morrison’s stuff isn’t accessible
enough for casual viewers so I don’t expect
them to adapt it.
But the actual Anti-Life equation is this.
loneliness + alienation + fear + despair +
self-worth ÷ mockery ÷ condemnation ÷ misunderstanding
× guilt × shame × failure × judgment n=y
where y=hope and n=folly, love=lies, life=death,
self=dark side
Mark Hamill’s character is going to be a
lot of fun.
He’s playing the classic version of The
Trickster.
In the comics, the modern incarnation is a
new person who steals all of the Tricksters
equipment and uses it to start committing
crimes.
On the show.
Mark Hamill will be a prisoner in Iron Heights
with John Wesley Shipp.
I hope they get a scene together.
You can view it as a spiritual sequel to his
episode on the classic Flash series.
So in that timeline he was caught, thrown
in jail and has been there ever since.
In the new episode, there’s supposed to
be a new person calling themselves the Trickster
who will be like an imposter.
And the real Trickster, Mark Hamill, will
help Team Flash take him down.
Andrew Kriesberg said that he flipped when
he found out Mark Hamill accepted the invitation
to come on the show.
Sinceriously, it’s going to be awesome.
That’s pretty much it in terms of Rogues
they’ve already announced on the show.
Mark Hamill is in Episode 17, so that only
leaves about 3 episodes before the two part
finale.
And they’re probably not going to introduce
new character in the last two episodes.
If we see any more Rogues it would have to
happen between episode 18 and 20.
Mirror Master would be my next pick.
There have been rumors that Weather Wizard
will come back.
Either his brother will take the mantle or
they’ll twist logic and bring the Clyde
Martin version back from the dead.
Everyone thinks he’s dead because Joe shot
him at the end of episode 1.
The show mixes and matches villains.
Some of the characters it’s used have been
Firestorm villains, some have been Suicide
Squad members.
We don’t know the titles for the last couple
of episodes, but I think we knew what the
last couple of Arrow Episode titles were in
season 2 by the end of February.
Right now they’ve got about 6 more episodes
to film.
Maybe 7.
So by the time we see Episode 10, they’ll
probably be shooting Episode 15 or 16.
In related news, I like everyone’s Harrison
Wells theories.
And Yes, I do agree that there are two versions
of The Reverse Flash on the show.
But I don’t think we’ll see the writers
make that clear until the last couple of episodes.
Remember that in the comics, the Hunter Zolomon
Zoom had the Lenses covering his eyes and
Eobard Thawne didn’t have anything covering
his eyes.